public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente jean
pierre raffarin est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir monsieur
raffarin
bonsoir monsieur grossiord d'espoir à
tous et merci d'être avec nous vous
inaugurez cette nouvelle émission ce
nouveau rendez-vous de public sénat avec
nos nouveaux partenaires radio classique
et les échos et toujours avec la fp donc
on se retrouvera désormais chaque mardi
en direct à 18h30 et pour 45 minutes
trois grandes parties veut pour ceux ci
trois grandes parties lors de l'épreuve
de vérité à chaque fois une grande
question monsieur raffarin la première
faut-il adapter l'état de droit à la
menace terroriste jean-francis pécresse
de radio classique et des échos vous
posera la question dans un instant la
deuxième question alain juppé que vous
soutenez tiendra-t-il la distance face à
nicolas sarkozy oui suite répondez vous
tout de suite mais tout est l'heure
c'est nadège pull jacques de l' agence
france-presse qui vous posera la
question enfin la troisième adressée au
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense est ce que
l'armée française est à bout de souffle
les hauts gradés disent que vraiment ils
n'ont plus les moyens de mener les
guerres qu'on leur demande
mais qu'est la messe de public sénat
sera là tout à l'heure mais d'abord jean
pierre raffarin
cette première question d'actualité
frans françois hollande et manuel valls
affirme encore aujourd'hui assez
fortement contre la direction d'alstom
que le site de belfort vivra est-ce que
vous soutenez l'exécutif dans son bras
de fer avec ce groupe industriel
j'ai sauvé alstom en 2003 2004 quand
c'est est en grande difficulté
je suis pour qu'on défende cette
entreprise et son implantation à belfort
je soutiens évidemment le gouvernement
dans son bras de fer mais le
gouvernement agit bien tardivement
je rappelle que le gouvernement a est au
capital d'alstom qu'il avait le temps de
voir venir et que d'autre part nous
payons là l'échec de la politique
ferroviaire du gouvernement qui supprime
en l'écotaxe s'est contraint à ne plus
avoir les financements pour permettre un
aménagement du territoire national qui
donne offert aux rails tout simple vous
sanctionnez doublement le gouvernement
est ce qu'il ya eu selon vous des
faïences et vacances du gouvernement
puisque vous nous dites effectivement
qu'il avait tout bien formés bien
vacances défaillance quand je vois que
les élus j'entendrai cédric perrin le
sénateur de belfort à l'instant quand je
vois que les élus sont informés aussi
tardivement et que l'état est
actionnaire à 20% mais qu'a fait l'état
dans tout cela
et là se pose la question de monsieur
macron depuis on a négligé ces dossiers
ce dossier on le voit venir ça ne se
prend pas comme ça une décision de cette
nature
et quand on a supprimé les contacts on a
supprimé les investissements des régions
en matière ferroviaire
on a supprimé les modernisations grande
partie de la sncf et donc en ne donnant
pas les moyens aux trains notamment
parce qu'on n'a pas fait l'écho taps on
se trouve dans la situation aujourd'hui
de déficit donc les responsabilités sur
ce dossier sont l'autre alors
aujourd'hui on soutient le bras de fer
mary soutenu quand même on pense quand
même que les choses auraient pu être
traités autres mais vous pensez que l'on
peut même si vous rappelez effectivement
que la sncf et exemple aujourd'hui n'a
pas les moyens est ce que vous pensez
néanmoins qu'on peut sauver le site de
belfort et bien sûr on peut on peut
soutenir et le manque de belfort
simplement en donnant aux rails français
la place qui doit avoir c'est à dire en
faisant en sorte que la commande
publique sert notre industrie et quand
j'entends dire que
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui comment des
français je voudrais savoir comment font
les autres pour que ce soit d'une
manière générale les pays qui sont des
pays très partenaires de la france qui
eux prennent les commandes dans leur
propre industrie et que nous on pourrait
pas aller les français ne nous ramène
justement la question de la productivité
de la rentabilité des sites français et
de la terrible et désespérante
désindustrialisation du pays jean pierre
of fame et quand on est au capital
depuis aussi longtemps que les états sur
alstom
tout ceci s'anticipe il ya une
responsabilité d'actionnaire de l'état
dans cette affaire puis donc l'état
aurait dû anticiper que le fait d'abord
donné les investissements dans le rail
conduisait à des difficultés chez alstom
mais ces chambres jour de sortie de
l'ena pour comprendre hectares mais vous
préconisez la même solution que le
gouvernement s'est éteinte demandé à la
sncf de passer commande
mais à condition qu'il y ait des projets
pour la sncf s'il n'y a pas de projet on
va être anglais la sncf met donc toute
la question c'était nous nous avions
fait avec l'écotaxe d'une part mais
aussi quand on avait une agence qui
s'appelait lafitte pour aider des
investissements est de faire en sorte
quand avant la privatisation des
autoroutes l'argent j'étais contre cette
privatisation
mais l'argent qu'on avait des autoroutes
on le mettait dans l'investissement pour
le transport aujourd'hui on a fait trop
pour le routier est passé pour le reiki
question est ce qu'on la nationalisation
même temporaire est envisageable
je crois que c'est de mauvaise la
proposition mal à pierre chevènement ou
marion maréchal-le pen je pense que
l'état n'est pas fait pour gérer des
entreprises de cette nature qui doivent
une ambition internationale
en revanche l'état par la commande
publique peut compter et peser grâce à
la capacité non seulement de commandes
mais aussi d'innovations et de soutien à
toute la recherche
nous avons la capacité aujourd'hui de
vendre des voitures aux etats-unis et on
pourrait pas le faire pour la france
donc il faut le faire pour la france
mais ça on a besoin d'une stratégie rail
dans le pays
voilà qui est dit à leur première grande
partie thématique mettant de l'épreuve
de vérité jean pierre raffarin et donc
nous accueillons jean-francis pécresse
de radio classique et des échos je vous
le rappelle nos nouveaux partenaires
france soir
les échos est votre questions à notre
invité première question est ce que vous
êtes de ceux qui pensent qu'il faut
tordre un peu notre notre état de droit
pour l'adapter aux risques terroristes
je crois qu'il faut pas tordre l'état de
droit l'état de droit c'est là où se
puise l'autorité j'aime bien quand il ya
les discours de fermeté quand on prend
des postures et qu'est ce que c'est que
l'autorité
l'autorité c'est de la force qui
s'appuie sur le droit il faut faire
respecter les règles celui qu'a de
l'autorité c'est celui qui fait
respecter les règles y compris à soi
même donc l'état de droit est quelque
chose qu'on ne doit pas bousculés à
chaque instant par exemple on nous a dit
pendant quinze jours qu'il fallait
changer la constitution pour le burqini
aujourd'hui plus personne ne parle du
burkina donc si on change les choses
comme ça
systématiquement en fonction de
l'actualité on a un désordre du droit
qui nuit 1la l'autorit là c'est plus
lent et c'est plus l'actualité que
st-pierre a faim c'est la menace
terroriste comme l'europe oui mais une
situation guère c'est non mais non mais
si c'est pour vous montrer le bureau
l'état de droit on aurait fait un
congrès pour réformer il ya quinze jours
la constitution pour le burqini donc moi
je ne suis pas pour que tous les quinze
jours on est un état de droit
déstabiliser qu'il faille de temps en
temps réforme mur je pense que pour ce
qui est par exemple des fiches s et qu'
on puisse mettre hors d'état de nuire un
certain nombre de gens il faut dans le
cas des fiches s identifier ceux qui ont
vraiment commis des délits et des crimes
donc qu'il puisse y avoir des réflexions
juridique sur ce sujet là pour nous
donner le moyen juridique de donner le
moyen au juge état de droit d'avoir la
possibilité de mettre hors d'état de
nuire des personnes c'est tout à fait
faux ce qu'elle forme sous la forme
d'une rétention administrative sous le
contrôle du juge
au préalable est ce que sur ce sujet là
vous êtes en phase avec ce que sarkozy
propose par exemple un peu de moi je
connais bien les propositions d'alain
juppé je ne regarde pas tous les matins
ce que dit sarkozy c'est très bien mais
il a été aux responsabilités j'ai vu ce
qu'il a fait sur ces sujets donc je
regarde ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
de nouveau et c'est ce que propose alain
juppé c'est sous l'autorité du juge un
état de droit c'est l'autorité du juge
il faut donner aux juges les moyens
d'agir parce que vous savez on parle des
fichiers hespel les gens ne savent pas
toujours ce que c'est malheureusement
ces rappels réguliers mais vous savez
comment on en est un
on peut être écoutée à un moment parce
que vous êtes dans un réseau ceci ou
cela et donc mais on sait sur une écoute
téléphonique qu'on peut décider de vous
mettre dans une pique donc c'est pas
parce que forcément vous avez participé
à coups de fil que vous êtes forcément
systématiquement donc en situation
d'être un dangereux terroriste donc il y
à un certain nombre de précautions à
prendre dans un état de droit c'est aux
juges leur souvent vous entendez nicolas
sarkozy parlait hier soir dans un
meeting à provins de pesto noir à propos
de la menace terroriste
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire est-ce que
lors d'avant avec les porn et dons parce
que l'excès la mythique moi même donc je
vais la campagne pour alain juppé donc
se passe pas mon temps c'est assez
amusant on peut pas parler avec les
médias aujourd'hui vous avez deux sets
zéro panne
si on ne parle pas de nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy je le respecte c'est
quelqu'un de très bien mais moi je fais
la campagne de la jupe et donc tous les
soirs je fais des meetings pour alain
juppé je parle de la gravité de la
situation je parle de sa solidité je
parle de son projet et puis ma foi je ne
cherche pas apparaît systématiquement de
nicolas sarkozy je pense que peste noire
ça rappelle des mauvaises périodes
donc ce sont pas forcément les mots très
pertinent mais bon je n'ai pas écouté le
discours dans le monde de ce week end je
crois michel serres qui est un
philosophe et du dos et 86 ans dit en
substance on surestime le risque
terroriste on vit quand même malgré ce
risque en temps de paix et quand on
quand on comptabilise au fond le nombre
de morts dus aux actes terroristes en
france et en europe
on en fait presque trop alors évidemment
je le caricature un peu mais c'est un
peu le sens de ce qu'il voulait dire
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça
pas vraiment même si j'ai un profond
respect pour michel cercle
ce qui compte dans l'état de guerre
c'est la puissance de la menace et la
menace elle est réelle la menace elle
est pas artificielle et beaucoup de gens
ont peu
ils ont peur pour eux mêmes ils ont peur
pour leurs enfants ils ont peur pour
leur leurs amis ils ont peur et donc ce
qui caractérise notre état de guerre
c'est que nous avons un adversaire qui
manipulent l'horreur avec une
gourmandise pathologie qui nous effraie
et donc qui créé des troubles dans notre
propre société qui est vraiment
significative d'un état de guerre
donc c'est vrai qu'on peut aller au
cinéma c'est vrai qu'on peut se promener
c'est vrai qu'on peut passer à travers
mais il n'empêche qu'il y a dans la
société une pesanteur
parce que c'est vrai que les menaces
sont jour et que quand on est informé
des renseignements qui sont aujourd'hui
à la disposition par exemple des
parlementaires il ya quand même des
menaces lourdes et sérieuses qui pèsent
sur la sécurité du pays je vais vous
apporter la preuve maintenant jean
pierre raffarin que les médias ne sont
pas les seuls à parler de nicolas
sarkozy on va écouter françois hollande
et manuel valls qui l'interpellent et
critique le danger qu'ils représentent
très justement en évoquant la remise en
cause de l'état de droit et vaut réagir
et ils se trompent
nicolas sarkozy il s'est trompé en 2012
sur la lecture de la menace terroriste
quant aux à l'époque il avait évoqué les
crimes de mera comme celui d'un loup
solitaire
il s'est trompé comme président de la
république sur l'étendue de la menace
puisque il a affaibli notre sécurité et
notre défense en faisant baisser les
investissements les moyens en hommes en
femmes dans nos forces de sécurité
intérieure extérieure
il se trompe sur la méthode en essayant
de tordre le cou à l'état de droit je ne
laisserai pas
la france est abîmée réduite voire ses
libertés mise en cause son état de droit
contester son éducation réduite et sa
culture amputé c'est le combat d'une vie
est ce que nicolas sarkozy est un danger
pour notre état de droit
mais ce qui est très claire dans ce
qu'on vient d'entendre là c'est qu'au
fond le président de la république
il rêve d'une chose d'un match avec
nicolas sarkozy il veut rejouer le match
de 2012 et au fond qui dans le pays a
envie qu'on rejoue le match
sarkozy hollande ce match était le match
de 2012
ce n'est pas le match de 2010 est donc
moi ce que je note ici et pour bien
connaître les uns et les autres c'est
qu'au fond françois hollande craint
alain juppé et qu' il choisit son
concurrent préféré est choisi nicolas
sarkozy et puis donc une sorte de
dialectique on avait déjà vu ça à propos
du congrès vous vous souvenez quand il
s'agissait de la déchéance de
nationalité on avait vu que nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande avait des
positions assez voisines ce que je crois
c'est que la gauche aujourd'hui a de
fortes probabilités de ne pas être au
second tour le président de la
république affaiblie sur sa droite par
macron affaibli sur sa gauche par
montebourg a peu de chances d'être au
second tour
donc ceux qui nous écoutent là ils
doivent bien se dire que le match de la
présidentielle au mois de mai va se
jouer en novembre quel match
préférez-vous le pen
juppé ou le pen sarkozy j'ai choisi moi
je préfère confier à alain juppé ce
combat contre valable peine mais se
prenait midi stress qui a pas une chose
qui vous intrigue un peu
est ce que c'est que dans tout le débat
sur le terrorisme mais aussi sur la
question de l'islam
ce débat là à droite et à gauche
d'ailleurs se fait autour de ce que
propose nicolas sarkozy est pas alain
juppé est ce que il n'ya pas quelque
chose alors que les positions de l'un et
l'autre sont pas si différentes au fond
il ya elles sont différentes sur un
certain nombre de points de pointe
détails mais sur
l'essentiel sur la rétention sur le
regroupement en termes de d'immigration
aussi vous êtes assez proches pourquoi
est-ce que le débat marque plus du côté
de c'est tout simple parce qu'il ya une
gourmandise médiatique pour nicolas
sarkozy a selon moi bien on voit mais
bien sûr que si regarder
systématiquement net interrogé sur
nicolas sarkozy est systématiquement on
doit répondre
on a un projet on a notre programme donc
je vous le dis moi je veux pas passer
tout mon temps à propos de nicolas st
c'est une problématique médiatique c'est
parce que il ya une campagne la question
aujourd'hui c'est pas de choisir le plus
médiatique
ce n'est pas de choisir même celui qui
fait le campagne avec plus de
gourmandise c'est de savoir qui est le
plus solide et qui sera le meilleur
président moi je pense que alain juppé
c'est la bonne réponse à la situation de
gravité aujourd'hui je ne crois pas que
la campagne présidentielle du printemps
prochain sera une campagne sur les
promesses sur le marketing sur la
publicité ne se sera pas bien ce we can
demain tout est possible ce sera ou et
la solidité face à la gravité la
sécurité et face à la gravité économique
le chômage qui est solide en france qui
a les nerfs qui a le calme qui
aujourd'hui a le projet qui peut
rassembler lequel il entrait en creux
faites-vous du candidat dont vous voulez
pas content mais je parle d' alain juppé
il est il est un homme de rassemblement
moi je préfère la stratégie du
rassemblement à l'astre été du climat
je comprends que d'autres peuvent
proposer le clivage la mobilisation des
nôtres contre les eau etc
je comprends tout cela moi je suis pour
la stratégie du rassemblement
c'est cela je crois alors ça fait
peut-être pas de débat mais je vais vous
dire une chose ça rassemble et français
et une campagne électorale une campagne
présidentielle il faut rassembler les
français questions rapides sur les
événements qui viennent de se produire
dans la prison dans une prison que vous
connaissez bien puisqu'elle est à côté
de chez vous poitiers vivonne c'est quoi
le sujet c'est un manque de place et un
manque de personnel qu'est-ce que c'est
un établissement je crois que vous aviez
inauguré vous-même absolument c'est un
établissement ce que j'avais fait un
programme de création de prison quand
j'étais
être bien ministre nous avions créé un
grand nombre de places et c'est
d'ailleurs été très arrêtée par la suite
seulement 13 minutes et nous avons aviv
ont créé une prison très moderne et ce
qui je pense est à la source de ces
événements en dehors de la chaleur et
des conditions difficiles de la période
il ya deux choses a dit par les moyens
de l'administration pénitentiaire ils
n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens et les
les efforts qu'on a faits nous sur les
infrastructures n'ont pas été suivies
par des efforts sur les personnels et
d'autre part je pense que ces prisons où
les prisonniers sont séparés sont isolés
craie naturellement une résistance des
prisonniers moi quand je suis allé à
nouveau dans cette prison m'a dit vous
savez elle est moins convivial qui ont
été celles des autres avant alors avant
naturellement le soir on mettait dans
les pièces où il y avait quatre
personnes on mettait des matelas pour
ils doivent alors c'était peut-être
conviviale mais d'abord un c'était
condamné par la cour des droits de
l'homme et 2 ça donnait une contagion
des difficultés et là les gens sont
isolés
c'est peut-être moins convivial mais il
faut savoir si la après la prison c'est
un club ou si au contraire c'est là pour
isoler un certain nombre de gens menace
on donne la question dernière question
on passe un peu à la matière économique
budgétaire
on voit que en ce moment tous les
candidats à la primaire à droite sont en
train de lâcher à un peu la bride sur le
déficit et notamment françois fillon qui
est prêt qui parle maintenant d'un
déficit au dessus de 4 et demi pour cent
du pib en 2010 est est ce que est ce que
alain juppé et vous vous inquiétiez
votre votre candidat est ce que vous
garantissez que vous ne dépasserez pas
les 3% de déficit
c'est vraiment un objectif c'est
vraiment un objectif très important il
faut dégager les marges de manoeuvre
pour nos priorités on parlera tout à
l'heure de défense on parlera on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui qu'on est en guerre
et laisser nos armées sans les budgets
qui sont nécessaires donc il est
nécessaire de faire des économies de
diminuer la dépense publique pour
infecter un certain nombre de dépenses
de sur des priorités et donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment donner ce cap des 3
%
et puis quand on est européen
ces règles on l'a défini ensemble il
faut assumer ce qu'on à définir ensemble
et donc la parole vis-à-vis de l'europe
c'est quelque chose qui compte pour eux
pas question d'aller re négocier non je
penserai moi j'ai eu l'occasion de le
faire discuter avec l'union européenne
je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans l'état de
crise de l'europe il faut que la france
soit digne d'être un bon élève de
l'europe est de faire en sorte que la
les économies budgétaires qui sont quand
même non pas l'intérêt de l'europe
mais l'intérêt des français soit dans la
nuit n'ont pas de deron magique déployés
par a pas de dérapage
merci monsieur raffin merci beaucoup
jean francis pécresse c'est maintenant
c'est nadège peljak de l' agence france
presse qui nous rejoint monsieur
raffarin l'épreuve de vérité avec les
bonjour monsieur raffarin
bonjour bonsoir manège votre ma question
ah bah vous allez vos courbes en vouloir
parce que je vais vous parler de
monsieur sarkozy retrouve autre chose et
ça c'est pas grave c'est pas grave alors
on y va
alain juppé donc vous le soutenez on a
bien compris est ce qu'il va tenir la
distance face à nicolas sarkozy
évidemment évidemment parce que
aujourd'hui non seulement il est en tête
dans les sondages il est déterminé mais
ça devait être quelque chose un coup de
tonnerre que l'entrée en campagne de
nouveaux candidats
il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
le panel s'élargit il ya des
effritements ici ou là je pense qu'il
est en tête qu'il est durablement en
tête je pense qu'il est très déterminé
il est très serein et je peux vous dire
que moi je suis très confiant je vois
aujourd'hui la campagne se dérouler de
manière très positive
je vois que quand devant les
entrepreneurs l'université d'été c'est
lui qui a été qualifié comme de
meilleurs des intervenants qui l'a vu
programme économique le plus crédible je
vois un sondage sur le terrorisme c'est
lui qui est le plus crédible sur les
priorités défendront en hiver il est le
plus crédible donc vraiment on a
confiance on va faire attention parce
que c'est pas gagné d'avancé mais il est
clair que aujourd'hui madame le pen
apparaît comme une candidate au second
tour très crédible et que pour battre
manable peine aujourd'hui on voit bien
que se dégage une ligne stratégique
importante c'est celle d'alain juppé
alors je veux revenir sur ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure à mon confrère
jean francis pécresse
vous parliez de stratégie de
rassemblement à vous disiez je préfère
la stratégie de rassemblement
sous-entendu celle de monsieur juppé à
la stratégie de combat sous entendu
celles de clivage de clivage vous avez
dit effectivement j'ai compris de combat
doivent se ressemblent quelquefois un
peu alors deux clivages de toute façon
ça n'a pas d'importance à ne change rien
à mes questions
oui dit il faut rassembler les français
certes pour 2017
mais là on est à la primaire 2016 il
s'agit de rassembler les français de
droite à cette primaire c'est le
français de droite qui vont aller voter
monsieur raffarin s'est pas assez pas
les français de gauche mais bien sûr que
d'abord les français de gauche en a plus
beaucoup
oui mais enfin regarder dans lé jour là
dans les législatives devaient les
partiels ils ont ils étaient peu
présents il ya des gens qui ont la
conscience ce gaucher des gens qui ont
voté hollande a mais aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas beaucoup d'électeurs du parti
social alors revenu à ma question alors
comment on fait pour rassembler les
france alors d'abord je vais vous dire
de droite
alors justement ça c'est très important
il faut penser à la première étape mais
on ne fait pas des primaires pour les
primaires ont fait les primaires pour
choisir un président de la république
donc on pense naturellement à la
situation dans laquelle on va se
retrouver au 4e tour c'est-à-dire au
deuxième tour des présidentielles
demander aux français de réfléchir quel
est le meilleur candidat pour rendre
explique énormément mais je vais vous
dire c'est très simple est-ce qui est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut redresser la
france
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
redonner de la sécurité aux français
est-ce que vous pensez que face à la
gravité de la situation il faut mettre
de la solidité dans la politique
français si vous pensez ça vous devez
choisir le meilleur candidat au premier
tour le meilleur candidat au premier
tour de la primaire ce n'est pas le
meilleur candidat électorale ce n'est
pas le plus tapageur
ce n'est pas le plus agité ce n'est pas
celui qui va faire le plus de voix non
non non mais pas du tout donne pas du
tout je dis je crois mais peut-être mais
c'est pas comme ça que je le dis moi je
dis simplement voilà le fait que je vote
pour le plus serein le plus calme
celui qui va pouvoir rassembler et si je
vais aux primaires ce n'est pas pour les
primaires ce n'est pas un match dans
l'est républicain
il s'agit pas de savoir quel est le
meilleur républicain il ne s'agit pas de
savoir quel est le celui qui aujourd'hui
doit porter les couleurs du des
républicains il s'agit de choisir
le président pour les français pourquoi
faisons nous des primaires c'est pas
dans notre culture
le général de gaulle ne nous a pas
appris à faire des primaires pourquoi
faisons-nous du primaire parce que
madame le pen est à 25 ou 30%
c'est à dire que madame le pen elle est
sans doute au second tour et que si nous
nous avons deux candidats
nous serons comme lionel jospin en 2002
nous serons absent du second tour n'a
pas tout bousillé deux candidats énorme
et son tour en 2017 avait si on n'avait
pas de prix mais je vous dis ah si vous
n'êtes jubilaire je vous dis je vous
explique pourquoi nous on fait des
primaires
nous avons fait des primaires pour avoir
un candidat quand madame le pen car avec
des primaires nous mettons notre
candidat à 25-30 % c'est-à-dire qu'il
est qualifié au second tour si nous
avions une candidature juppé par une
candidature sarkozy tous les deux
seraient éliminés comme il y a eu la
candidature jospin la colline nature
chevènement l'aco nature taubira qu'il
fait que monsieur jospin en 2002 a été
nous voulons éviter l'élimination
donc si nous avons fait une primaire ce
n'est pas pour désigner notre champion
pour que les républicains est un
champion c'est pour désigner celui qui
va battre madame le pen au deuxième tour
de la présidentielle
c'est pour ça que nous faisons des
primaires et de ce point de vue là
beaucoup de gens vont venir voter
alassane appel aux contenus et aux
électeurs justement jour qui vote
directement pour monsieur juppé dans
lequel figure que vous nous dites pour
qu'il soit lui les gris clair et
l'éclairé l'âme le n je lance un appel à
tous ceux qui ont un attachement à la
république à tous ceux qui partagent un
projet d'alternance qui veulent signer
la charte de nos valeurs je vous invite
à venir vous dire qu'ils aient voté
hollande qu'ils aient voté sarkozy
qu'ils aient voté x qu'ils aient voté y
maintenant il s'agit de parler de
l'avenir pour l'avenir quel est le
meilleur candidat que nous allons mettre
probablement face à madame le pen c'est
ça je vous écoute on a l'impression que
la gauche on n'en parle plus de toute
façon sera pas au second tour
prudence prudence mais regardez regardez
les élections législatives vous a vu
très souvent regardé les élections
régionales gronde à gauche il nous a pas
échappé qu'il avait pas de socialistes
dans la région nord aujourd'hui que les
socialistes avaient été éliminé aux
régionales il comprit d'un région paca
donc voyez bien qu'en même temps il ya
eu des problèmes électoraux et c'était
avant l'effondrement de monsieur
hollande dont
monsieur macron il peut être candidat
mais s'il est hors des primaires il sera
marginalisé ou fait s'il est dans la
même lignée la cote
moi je n'ai peur de personne je pense
que les gens intelligents qui peuvent
aider le pays
ça peut toujours être utile un moment
j'y reviens je suis pas un polémiste je
ne suis pas je respecte les personnes
donc il peut il veut servir unis c'est
très bien mais ce que je dis c'est qu'il
va avoir beaucoup de mal parce que où il
est candidat dans la primaire et à ce
moment là il a simplement à mon avis
beaucoup de difficultés ou s'il est pas
dans le cadre de la primaire
il est candidat marignale après ce sera
difficile donc je pense que il a sans
doute à l'avenir mais que c'est pas pour
le printemps 2010 r c'est mon sentiment
à propos je vois le dossier alsthom
je dis qu'il aurait mieux fait de s'en
occuper plutôt que de penser à sa
campagne la vraie un tout à l'heure à
propos des primaires je vous lance et de
quasiment 1 après un appel aux électeurs
de gauche qui peuvent se reconnaître
dans les valeurs je pars en vous dites
de grand atout là tous les directeurs de
france et blanc mais tous ces électeurs
qui ont quitté la gorge accord le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que la gauche
n'a plus suffisamment d'électeurs et on
le voit quand vous voyez que dans ces
élections législatives la gauche
disparaît du soda s'il ya quand même une
plume présidentielle c'est différent on
a l'impression que chacun rentre dans sa
jeunesse mais écoute juillet peut-être
monsieur jospin il a été présent en 2002
au second tour monsieur jospin c'est
monsieur le pen qui était présent et
vous croyez que madame le pen n'a pas
progressé par rapport à son père
justement je crois que les électeurs de
gauche s'en souviennent et lestement
c'est pour ça qu'ils rendent dans leur
case peut-être peut-être qu'ils peuvent
rentrer dans leurs cases mais à ce
moment là il faut le dire à monsieur
montebourg qui rentrent dans la même
case de monsieur macro qui rendent à la
même place de monsieur hollande tient ça
fait peur tout l'air alors grâce à fait
beaucoup de bien de la primaire décidées
après leurs primes avait alors beau de
votre cri maire jean pierre raffarin
vous allez nous dire après coup après
avoir écouté nicolas sarkozy si vous
avez des inquiets sur le déroulé de la
compétition et de l'alberta est de plus
en plus aiguisée car nicolas sarkozy
avait dit ceci l'autre jour je ne parle
pas d'un code de bonne conduite je
n'aime pas le code de bonne conduite
j'aime la bonne conduite et quand il
faut un code sait déjà qu'on est dans le
problème
c'est un peu rapide un propos de
tribunes moi je suis pour un code de
bonne conduite soit une différence de
plus pas pour moi un code de bonne
conduite c'est d'abord l'égalité entre
les candidats qui n'est pas un acquis
social des moyens du parti puisque les
autres que c'est tout ça à égalité qu'il
ya une transparence et donc et puis
surtout une éthique des primaires et
donc les tic des primaires c'est quoi
c'est qu'on soutienne celui qui arrive
naturellement en tête et donc que l'on
soit tous rassemblés ensuite pour celui
que les primaires auront dit ça c'est
l'éthique des primaires et de ce point
de vue là je ne suis pas pour attaquer
les autres c'est normal que nicolas
sarkozy le dise ce qu'il a envie de dire
c'est son droit
il se trouve que là je ne suis pas
d'accord mais je ne m'attaque pas alors
nous on parle de nicolas sarkozy d'alain
juppé onfray il ya les autres
quand même qu'est ce qu'il devienne et
pourquoi ça serait pas monsieur fillon
ou bruno le maire ou jean françois copé
ou nathalie kosciusko morizet il ya
quand même une femme dans votre frais
mère enfin vous avez oublier monsieur
mariton non mais sortant le tri pourtant
un mérite tout à fait excusable
voilà bien écoutez moi je pense que tous
les candidats
d'abord ils élargissent l'appel à la
population ils les âges et la base
électorale pour nos primaires et nous
avons une ambition qui est d'avoir au
moins trois millions de votants donc il
est important qu'il y ait des gens y
revient exalté en plus monsieur juppé
aura une chance on verra plus le liboux
couvrir oui on lit ça met plus y aura de
votants plus la primaire sera crédible
forte et entraînera le pays donc moi je
pense qu'il faut une primaire qui
dépasse les trois millions et de ce
point de vue là qu'on soit nombreux à
faire campagne a expliqué pourquoi il
faut voter
au fond on va dire aux gens la
présidentielle elle peut pas se passer
de vous mais attention car peut-être que
tout va se régler à la primaire et
baskets ou les chiens le gagnant de la
primaire sera le futur prise en otage
c'est pas sûr mais peut-être et je dis
aux gens ne laissez pas passer ce
tour-là si vous avez des convictions du
centre de non inscrits au coeur des
valeurs de la république
laissez pas passer pas de la droite
c'est de tourner non parce que je vais
au-delà
non non parce que la droite il est
évident qu'à droite on l'appelle est
évident pour lui la droite et le centre
mais on va au delà tous ceux qui veulent
participer à ces élections peuvent
participer à ces élections
ces livres c'est pratiquement gratuit
ces deux euros essais libres
c'est-à-dire contre
hand pas la carte du parti donc tout le
monde peut y participer
donc moi je souhaite une large
participation est de ce point de vue là
nathalie kosciusko par exemple vous avez
raison de souligner le problème de la
présence féminine
je pense qu'elle élargit la base
politique de la primaire et c'est très
laid c'est une rallier évidente du
second tour pour ça je pensais le second
tour je suis très prudent je ne sais pas
comment les choses se passeront il y
aura des négociations donc il faut alors
mise en avant qui sait qui rejoindra
monsieur juppé au deuxième tour pardon
michel désintérêt mais je ne le sais pas
et vous savez quand on est candidat
là je suis pas une petite ysaline sa
devise lundi françois fillon
cette affaire françois de sales vous a
pas échappé qu'il sera peut-être je suis
échappé je suis en campagne électorale
pour alain juppé comme vacher le rôle
pour alain juppé alors on verra après
pour les autres mais pour vous c'est mon
cas on verra au deuxième tour mais pour
le moment ne me faites pas dire ce que
je n'ai pas envie de dire c'est à dire
moi je suis là à là où parler d'un super
on verra il y aura peut-être des
surprises au soir du premier tour de
cette primaire puisque vous citez
françois fillon nadège et l'un de ses
lieutenants bruno retailleau dit comme
lui à savoir que les sondages
actuellement la qui place votre champion
en tête lui n ont aucune valeur on
écoute bruno retailleau et vous
réagissez
j'ai vécu beaucoup d'élections les
sondeurs se trompe souvent ils se
trompent sur des élections classiques
comment voulez-vous qu'il sonde un corps
électoral qui est inconnu de tout ce
qu'on sait pas qui va voter alors
j'aimerais bien savoir j'aimerais bien
connaître des échantillons ça ne veut
rien dire
vraiment il faut pas que les français se
laissent confisqué se laisse voler
justement ni par les médias ni par le
sondeur
cette élection les primaires qui
déterminera sans doute le champion
ensuite aux présidentielles voilà il dit
la même chose que vous ferez une prime
et requiert pas je te passe sur terre et
rober par les médias notamment avec
bruno retailleau nous sommes d'accord
sur vraiment l'essentiel est sûr
beaucoup beaucoup de sujets dont je suis
complètement d'accord et la vraie
réponse allait démocratique
c'est un taux de participation très
élevé à la primaire les vingt-sept enfin
les sondages qui veulent rien dire vous
êtes d'accord
je pense qu'il faut pas accorder
d'importance aux sons à moi si je suis
confiant pour un montant vous le disiez
tout à l'heure
monsieur juppé était en tête dans les
sondages mais pas mais moi sur les jeux
fait campagne
j'étais à châteauroux avant-hier je peux
vous dire qu'il y a une dynamique il y a
une ambition il ya des projets
il ya vraiment quelque chose qui se
passe pour alain juppé et donc les gens
ont conscience de la gravité du pays et
va quelqu'un de solide donc ça se sent
sur le terrain je n'ai pas besoin de
sondage pour sentir ça donc je suis
content c'est parce que je trouve ça
marche bien alors alors une question
nous sommes si vous deviez qualifié la
principale qualité est de monsieur juppé
et puis ensuite de monsieur sarkozy
encore sarkozy où iriez quoi la
principale qualité de monsieur juppé
c'est la solidité et de nicolas sarkozy
c'est l'énergie est leur principal
défaut je pense que nicolas sarkozy jugé
il est plutôt dans une logique de
clivage c'est ça que je trouve que c'est
bah c'est pas idéal
et puis alain juppé ma foi j'ai du mal à
lui trouver quelques défauts je vais en
chercher je vais je vous ai entendu dire
il ya un instant jean pierre raffarin
qu'alain juppé était le mieux à même de
rassembler les français face à la menace
du front national je vous ai bien
entendu
et pourtant manuel valls lui dit la même
chose à propos de la gauche il a cet
argument est dit que la gauche est la
mieux placée pour rassembler les
français car une partie de la droite est
gangréné par l'extrême droite
est-ce que d'abord vous avez la même
analyse que lui sur cette porosité des
thèses des idées entre la droite et
l'extrême droite une partie de la droite
non si on parle des électeurs il est
clair qu'il ya des proximités parce que
le pays
glisser à droite c'est clair si on parle
des responsables et des élus il est
clair qu'on ne peut pas assimiler la
droite et l'extrême droite il est clair
que personne ne veut d'alliance personne
n'a cherché à avoir des rapprochements
des débauchages tout cela donc tout ceci
n'existe pas ce biais existe quelqu'un
un glissement à droite de l'électorat
donc je pense qu'il faut être attentif à
cela et qu'il faut pas chercher à courir
derrière le front national
mieux vaut affronter ses idées et
combattre le front national sur ses
idées donc par exemple ce qu'ils
proposent sur l'euro sur la politique
économique ce set petit comique est une
politique qui me paraît plutôt à gauche
qu'à droite
donc il ya un certain nombre de sujets
sur lequel il faut combattre le front
national mais très franchement
aujourd'hui
ce qui me paraît important c'est de
boire que il ya très peu de gens qui
sont passionnés par les partis
politiques
aujourd'hui les déçus de la gauche sont
importants il ya aussi beaucoup de déçus
de la droite donc il faut parler à tous
les français qui veulent qu'on sorte un
peu de cette politique traditionnelle de
secte image habituelle et qui veulent
s'exprimer pour pouvoir sortir le pays
du bourbier dans lequel une
recomposition du paysage politique en
france c'est les français qui en
décideront on va voir un peu ce que les
français pensent de sa vidéo ça ça veut
dire encore quelque chose d'être de
droite de gauche du centre et jeu
contraint de changer je pense que
l'extrême gauche est identifiable
l'extrême droite est identifiable et que
pour le reste il ya des gens qui sont
plus girondins plus jacobin plus
interventionniste et plus libéraux et
plus l'environnement tôt que d'autres y
a il ya un certain nombre de paramètres
mais on trouve des gens qui sont très
engagées pour l'environnement à droite
et d'autres qui le sont moins à gauche
et puis et vice versa donc il y à un
certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels
dans le pays
il ya un grand groupe central c'était la
thèse de de giscard les 60% de français
l'année deux tiers des français qui sont
au milieu et qui ont des idées voisine
mais ce que vous imaginez par exemple
demain alain juppé élu à l'élysée
prendre des ministres venus de la gauche
par exemple ont dit qu'ils apprécient
monsieur le drian à la défense vous le
connaissez très bien vous également
est-ce que c'était envisageable cette
ouverture est ce que c'est en une longue
ouverture envisageable avec alain juppé
oui ça vous savez la fonction
présidentielle je le connais bien c'est
à lui de répondre à cette question n'est
pas à moi donc ça je ne répondrai pas à
cette question
cette aube mais je pense vraiment qu'il
ya suffisamment de gens de la droite du
centre et des bons experts de la société
civile pour faire un gouvernement sans
aller faire du débauchage mais il ya des
gens qui ont de la qualité et donc ça
c'est au président la république
d'arbitré en fonction de sa propre
majorité
en fonction de la manière dont se sera
déroulé son élection merci beaucoup
nadège voilà troisièmes par ici vous de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
mickaël zeze de public sénat qui arrive
enfin mickaël bon sens michel bonsoir
monsieur enfin bonsoir président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées ou c'est là
donc vous poser ces questions-là
on attend beaucoup ça craque de partout
l'armée est à bout de souffle c'est le
cas je ne dirais pas cela c'est un peu
excessif l'alarmé sous une grande
tension est aujourd'hui toutes nos
forces projetable sont projetés et qu'il
est aujourd'hui très difficile par
exemple d'engager une nouvelle opération
sans se désengager d'une autre donc je
pense que nous sommes au taquet et il
est important de revoir par exemple
opération sentinel lui met un peu de
flexibilité
je pense qu'il ya des à s'attendre aux
oies veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on
se permet des postes
ça veut dire qu'on peut pas non
mobiliser des gens aussi longtemps dans
des conditions si difficiles quand vous
envoyez pendant huit semaines sur des
lits de camp dans les casernes à paris
les jeunes qui viennent de province que
vous le déraciner un peu de leur famille
tout ceci quelquefois pour faire des
gardes statiques
il ya sans doute une utilisation plus
rationnelle plus efficace de ce soutien
de la défense qui est très important à
la sécurité du pays mais ça doit être
aménagé donc il y a là des réflexions
qu'ils sont engagés
l'université d'été de la défense a
évoqué tous les sujets la semaine
dernière je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre de progrès à faire
françois hollande l'avait on avait parlé
ils voulaient réduire le nombre de
personnels sur une opération sentinel
avant les menaces d'attentât et avant
les attentats notamment pour
l'assassinât du prêtre en france et
finalement des revenus à plus de 7000
hommes sur le terrain je pense que vous
avez à combien aujourd'hui le nombre de
personnels nécessaires sur le terrain
je pense qu'il faut pouvoir monter à 10
milles mais il faut pouvoir en période
où les menaces sont moins fortes pouvoir
redescendre significativement notamment
à 7 mai donc dakhla question très
importante aujourd'hui c'est la question
de notre budget les capacités comme
qu'on peut avoir donc d'où la nécessité
pour répondre tout à l'heure la question
du déficit budgétaire de de faire des
efforts partout pour pouvoir monter le
plus vite possible à un budget de 2 % du
corps l'objet d'un consensus je vois
droite gauche on n'est pas encore tous
d'accord sur la date à laquelle on n'a
rien
et ils tous d'accord dans les
propositions à droite que nicolas
sarkozy et quelques autres donc il y a
je pense vraiment un travail qui est
important à faire pour soutenir notre
défendre non seulement la défense c'est
pour notre sécurité est essentielle mais
aussi c'est essentiel aujourd'hui pour
l'innovation et notre politique
industrielle
nous avons aujourd'hui une industrie de
la défense qui est remarquable et nous
avons une responsabilité nouvelle
maintenant que les britanniques ont
quitté l'europe continentale l'europe
qui assure en première ligne qui a la
plus grande armée capable de ce prochain
extérieur c'est la france et la france
est obligée de faire des efforts penser
que les allemandes à le revendre marge
également leur les allemands vont
augmenter leur budget de 7 % l'année
prochaine
donc ils ont pris bien conscience que le
bric site nous impose des efforts
c'était très mauvais coup à l'europe de
défense c'est le décide le break 6 7
c'est un mauvais coup mais peut-être que
ça peut être le sursaut pour engager des
initiatives nouvelles serres qu'il faut
continuer la coopération et plus royaume
uni parce que c'est la deuxième armée
avec laquelle nous avons à coopérer donc
nous avons des travaux à faire
mais au total je pense que la réflexion
franco allemande sur ces sujets je sais
que les italiens ils sont associés je
pense que c'est important parce que
d'abord c'est un socle fondateur est
essentielle
je crois qu'il nous faut vraiment dire
aux français qu'on a besoin d'une forte
défense non seulement pour nous projeter
à l'extérieur et assurer la paix mais
aussi pour faire en sorte que l'on
puisse protéger sur le territoire
national des français et qu'on puisse
soutenir nos emplois et nos industries
si vous permettez je prenais un exemple
la loi de programmation militaire elle
prévoit la mobilisation de douze avions
de chasse il ya eu la syrie il ya le
sahel
évidemment le mali l'irak à tous les
citer on en utilise aujourd'hui plus de
20 comment est-ce que ce n'a pas du tout
été anticipé dans toutes les lois de
programmation aujourd'hui comment il ya
ce qu'on appelle les contrats
opérationnels et il ya un excellent
rapport au sénat qui vient de sortir que
je vous recommande de jacques gauthier
daniel renner sur les opex c'est à dire
les opérations extérieures et sur
l'utilisation des moyens et on
s'aperçoit que tous les contrats
opérationnels sont globalement dépassé
et donc
en effet il n'ya pas eu une anticipation
d'une telle pression internationale les
pressions internationales qui est quand
même particulièrement difficile il
n'était pas évident de penser que la
russie ait voulu comme à l'idée qu'elle
évolue et que l'iran que l'arabie
saoudite que la bataille l'arabie
saoudite et iront naturellement la crise
syrienne et la crise en irak la crise
libyenne et son impact sur la tunisie on
a aujourd'hui des risques majeurs qui
font qu'on a besoin de faire un effort
justement vous parlez de la syrie la
trêve des combats est entrée en vigueur
depuis hier soir c'est la dernière
chance pour sauver le pays je pense que
c'est très important mais naturellement
ça des conséquences diplomatiques
important aussi parce que les russes
dans cette affaire joue un rôle très
important et d'une manière générale on
voit que les états unis ont sans doute
quelque part donné une sorte de feu vert
à ce qui pourrait être une compréhension
je ne parle pas d'alliance entre la
russie et la turquie
ça veut dire une chose ça veut dire que
les américains sont des alliés que les
russes sont des partenaires mais qu'il
faut l'indépendance de la france en
matière de défense parce qu'on voit bien
que dans tous ces jeux la menace avait
quelque chose qui se vend et que la
france est absente et la france elle
sera elle est absente parce que
peut-être qu'elle a été trop alignée sur
les états unis ou au début de ce conflit
et donc je pense qu'il est très
important de revenir aux valeurs
d'indépendance nationale de 2010 reste
peu de temps je vais vous parler des
états unis de la campagne vous avez vu
peut-être l'image d'hillary clinton
choses près de sa voiture
la faute visiblement une bonne et le
money nous dit on ça peut changer la
campagne je ne sais pas je ne peux pas
vous dire je ne peux pas gravité ne
suffit pas donc je ne peux pas vous dire
si je pense que alors peut-être plus
largement est ce qu'il faut que tout
savoir et faire toute la transparence
pour la centaine de chefs d'état je
pense qu'on a besoin de connaître des
éléments de la santé des chefs d'état
oui c'est que c'est quelque chose
d'utile depuis condition que ces
informations soient justes et vérifiable
ce qui n'était pas tout à fait le cas
quand monsieur mitterrand s'est employé
d'un exercice donc je pense que ce set
c'est utile mais au fond il faut aussi
voir que tout ceci arrive à n'importe
quel âge que tout ceci peut arriver à
n'importe quel moment qu'il ya des
menaces toujours sur la santé des gens
donc il faut aussi regarder leur état de
santé et leur hectares
de calme et une sérénité jean pierre
raffin vous êtes un ami de la chine sait
pas si vous êtes également un ami du
dalaï lama qui va être reçue par des
sénateurs demain est ce que c'est une
rencontre que vous pourriez envisager
pour vous même les autorités françaises
ne le voit pas ne le voit pas et ont
décidé et il n'est pas reçue par les
instances du sénat l'ont reçue par des
sénateurs
et donc c'est une rencontre de nature
privée qui est fait par des sénateurs
dont je respecte la position mais moi en
tant que président de la commission des
affaires étrangères
je suis dans une éthique de
responsabilité et pas seulement dans une
éthique de conviction et dans mon
éthique de responsabilité
je veille à être conforme aux souhaits
de la diplomatie française et a pas me
retrouver nicolas d'afrique à sa cause
il avait reçu en 2008 françois hollande
ne leur soit pas en 2016 normal c'est
son épouse
je pense que nicolas sarkozy l'avait
reçue lundi la main agde ans ce qui
était un sujet qui avait fait pas mal de
bruit parce que je pense qu'il avait
envisagé de le faire avance parce qu'ils
avaient moins d'impact qu'en france en
france mais en fait pour les chinois ce
avait plus d'impact parce que c'était en
tant que président européen qu'il avait
reçu donc savez en chine eu beaucoup
d'impact
je pense que sur ces sujets et la
diplomatie française a pris une décision
c'est assez intéressant c'est quand les
socialistes sont au pouvoir on ne te
revient sur ce type de sujet pourquoi
france et la chine
mais quand il était dans l'opposition
ils ont fait beaucoup de choses citoyen
d'honneur de la ville de paris le dalaï
lama ne doit ni doit se sentir un peu un
peu abandonné abandonné par ses amis une
toute dernière question puisque avec
michael vous parliez des conflits qui
envoie sur les routes les flots de
réfugiés que l'on connaît le ministre de
l'intérieur on le sait veut supprimer la
jungle de calais et répartir douze mille
réfugiés un peu partout en france est-ce
que vous soutenez ce plan mis en oeuvre
par les préfets alors que vous nous
aviez dit ici même il ya quelques mois
qu'il fallait que effectivement les
villages de france accueille les jo
là on est on est sur des sujets très
différents
là il s'agit de gens qui doivent aller
en angleterre il s'agit pas des gens qui
cherchent leur intégration en france
donc ces gens là il faut faire en sorte
que soit ils retournent chez eux soit
qu'ils aillent en angleterre c'est pas
notre sujet donc je suis vraiment pour
que l'on puisse rediscuter et les
accords du touquet mais les positions
qui ont été prises sur ces sujets là il
ne s'agit pas d'accueillir des gens qui
veulent venir en france il s'agit des
gens qui veulent passer en france donc
où on les arrête avant où on les laisse
passer après mais on peut pas se trouver
ici en charge de la gestion de ce
problème qui ne nous concerne pas en
direct même si naturellement on est très
sensible à la condition de ces gens là
et qu'il faut rendre cette condition la
plus humaine possible
merci jean pierre raffarin merci michael
merci à tous
on se retrouve donc la semaine prochaine
pour le numéro deux de l'épreuve de
vérité à notre invité sera jean
christophe cambadélis le premier
secrétaire du ps très bonne soirée